how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder this
is going to be
my non-spoiler review of the falcon and
the winter soldier
episode 1. so there won't be any
spoilers about the episode in this video
but there are some very
important things that i think you should
know before going into the falcon and
the winter soldier series
this is a very very different show than
one division so
whether you liked one of vision or you
didn't like one division
here's a little information on what this
show is really like
and if you love marvel and you want to
stay up to date on all things mcu be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos
so a big question i have been getting is
is the falcon in the winter soldier
similar to one division and the answer
is no not only are these characters very
very different from each other but the
show is actually very different as well
one division was kind of this new
experiment that marvel did that i really
did enjoy
however some fans did say that even
though they did enjoy
one division it didn't really feel like
a marvel project
and if you feel that way i definitely
understand that the sitcom style type of
tv show
mixed with some dark undertones was kind
of new for everybody
but with the falcon and the winter
soldier right away you know
this is a marvel project it feels like a
marvel project
from everything down to the music to the
sound effects to the comedy to the
interaction between the characters to
the action
and to the reference of other characters
and the fact that this is entirely woven
inside of the mcu and that is referenced
and of course since this
is essentially a captain america
spin-off within the first couple of
minutes we see things relating to
captain america and there are some
pretty big scenes
involving good old cap not actually him
on screen so don't think that he's going
to show up but things that he's done
so right away it just feels like yes
another
marvel studios project another thing
that you need to know is that this
doesn't exactly feel like a tv show it
feels like a movie
now i know some people weren't exactly
thrilled about disney plus and
instead of them doing movies they're now
doing shows but keep in mind we're still
getting the same amount of movies and
they're adding the show so it's just
more content for us
but the series does feel like a movie
and that's because it had an
insanely big budget i think it was
rumored to be over 150 million dollars
and the way that director kari skoglyn
talked about shooting this series is she
said that they shot it
like a movie they shot six episodes so
six
hours worth of footage and then they
just edited it and cut it down to what
they wanted to show throughout these six
episodes
and i quite enjoyed it i did think that
it was very cinematic both
sam scenes and bucky scenes were both
done exceptionally well
it doesn't feel like it's any different
than actually watching a movie from the
graphics to the acting to the story
it feels like we're getting a captain
america spin-off movie that's based on
falcon and the winter soldier we're just
getting parts
one through six now the next thing i'll
talk about is the action in the show
a lot of really good action as you've
probably seen from the trailers there's
a lot of things that happen falcon
flying through the air helicopters
hand-to-hand combat they use guns they
use explosives
it's extremely fast-paced when they do
all of this and granted i've only seen
the first episode so far but everything
that they do involving the action
sequences and fighting is actually
pretty creative
the way that falcon fights and flies is
different than anything we've seen from
him in the past
and as we've seen from the trailers and
photos and promotions he does have a new
suit which they do talk about
now considering that this is the first
episode of the series and it's supposed
to be setting everything up they
actually do throw a
good amount of action in this episode
the episode is about 48 minutes long
now of course as disney has showed us
with one division the end credits are
about five minutes long
possibly even longer so let's go ahead
and say that there's 42 minutes of
actual footage
half of that is probably action
sequences with sam and bucky
but the other half has done
exceptionally well the story makes
a lot of sense it's very grounded it's
very real it addresses the questions
that we have all been wondering since
the end of avengers end game when
captain america gave sam the shield
and there's a reason for everything a
good reason behind
everything that takes place with sam and
with bucky because in the beginning
as most people know they have two
different stories throughout their time
together in the mcu they've had this
love-hate relationship they know each
other but their friends their teammates
they fought together alongside of their
best friend
captain america and they very much go
over each of their personal stories
before they get together in the first
episode and it's really cool to see
because this takes place a handful of
months after the events of avengers in
game
and of course just like wanda this
addresses what they're like
after the blip and keep in mind both of
them were indeed
snapped and that's something to keep in
mind because this show actually dresses
very
real things within the mcu as director
carrie skoglin said
if avengers in game was this huge
magical
out of this world story then the falcon
in the winter soldier is a very grounded
very real story it addresses things that
you really haven't thought about before
maybe in the back of your head you have
but things like where exactly do
superheroes get their money from so it's
a really good story that also
kind of has some shocks to it now it's
only the first episode so there's only
so much that can be developed but there
are a few parts during this episode
where you stop and you think
oh dang that's intense which is of
course something that you want you don't
want to be able to expect
everything you want to be surprised and
you are there are some good surprises in
this episode
some really cool that you'll really
enjoy and some that are pretty intense
like i mentioned before
and speaking of pretty intense this
episode actually does have a good amount
of
emotion in it now of course this show is
an action thriller but when it comes to
a movie or a tv
show it just can't be all action all the
time there has to be some
context behind everything there has to
be a good underlying story that gives
the action a purpose
and even though the action is amazing
and i could probably watch an entire
series just based off of action
the story and the emotion that comes
with it does back it up pretty well and
sets up what is about to happen
and i think some of the real world
actually resonates really well with what
is happening in the mcu because right
now we're in the middle of a pandemic
in the mcu they are right after the blip
right after everybody has come back
and that's something that is addressed
in this and it talks about how
it affected families and it shows the
aftermath of that again it's a very real
story
that hasn't exactly been addressed yet
we kind of got it in spider-man and far
from home but they really kind of made
light of the situation
kind of made a joke about people just
popping back up like
in the middle of a basketball game where
the band shows up which was a very
light-hearted way and kind of comedic
way to go about it because we still have
questions like
what happened to people who got dusted
in airplanes do they snap back in the
middle of the sky and fall to the ground
to their death
this episode doesn't answer that
question but it does address the effects
that the blip had
so within the falcon in the winter
soldiers first episode we have a lot of
action
that is very well done no bad cgi or
anything like that
an amazing story that goes along with it
that is a very real story about what is
actually happening within the mcu right
now
it has some surprises in it some of
which will shock you and some of which
you'll feel very very good about and be
very happy to see
it has a lot of emotion and it sets up
what is to come in the future episodes
and of course
last but not least anthony mackie and
sebastian stan of course
crushed it they've been playing these
characters for a very long time
sebastian stan has been playing bucky
since captain america the first avenger
in 2011 that's
10 years and anthony mackie has been
playing falcons since captain america
the winter soldier which was in 2014
which means he's been playing the
character for seven years so they really
know how to get into the minds of these
characters and it really does show on
screen
not just with the action and the jokes
but with the serious stuff as well
so big shout out to them and
congratulations to them for crushing
their roles
once again shout out to the director
carrie skoglin she did an amazing job
the writers all did a good job and the
cast and crew seemed to be pretty great
for the whole entire show
i loved one division i did but right now
i'd have to say that i like the falcon
and the winter soldier more and i've
only seen the first episode
i think that's primarily due to the
whole marvel field the show is much more
what we're used to so i think i like it
a little bit more due to that but
one division was still great but if
you're looking for that marvel
feel in a project you're going to love
the falcon and the winter soldier
so let me know how excited you are about
the falcon and the winter soldier in the
comments below
what do you want to see out of it be
sure to let me know and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos and of course i'll be doing a
watch party tomorrow night
it'll start at 11 50 p.m pacific time
see you all there tomorrow for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and i'm now
on tick tock doing different videos but
of course there's still marvel videos
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you